التفاصيل الدراميه لظهور بايدنا المفاجئ
في وسط كييف وحقيقه انحصار البحر في مصر
ولبنان وعلاقه ذلك بتسونامي قادم والتوثيق
للجميع شعار المرحله ومتى تنضم لتويتر
وتعلن اشتراكا شهريا مقابل التوثيق اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
اليوم وبشكل مفاجئ وغير متوقع ومن دون
سابق انذار ولا اعلان رسمي زر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف لساعات معدوده قبل ايام من الذكرى
الاولى للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه زياره
طبعا اثارت الصدمه ومعاها الكثير من
التساؤلات يعني كيف رئيس دوله ومو اي دوله
بل دوله بحجم امريكا يسافر نص العالم
ويظهر فجاه في دوله ثانيه دون سابق انذار
في استقبال بايدن كان فيزيلنسكي طبعا
والتقى بزوجته كمان وقيادات عسكريه
وسياسيه اوكرانيه وتجول في شوارع كلاب
وحيه جدار لضحايا الحرب كمان وخلال
الزياره وعد بحزمه اسلحه جديده واكد انه
سبب الزياره التاكيد على الدعم الامريكي
اللي لن يتزعزع
[موسيقى]
بدا الحبحث والسؤال عن التفاصيل كيف ومتى
وين وكل التفاصيل اللي الناس بتسال عنها
والتفاصيل حقيقه دراميه فاول اعلام البيت
الابيض من ايام بيتجنب اي سؤال عن زياره
لبيض وبينفي ثانيا نشر البيت الابيض جدول
الرئيس اللي اظهر انه الرئيس اليوم في
واشنطن وبكره رايح وارسو كل هذا والرئيس
اصلا وصل وورسو في بولندا ومن بعدها اخذ
قطار لمده 10 ساعات الى اوكرانيا هذا
الطريق كل المسؤولين الامريكيين من وقت
الحرب اخذوه لانه الطيران خطر في المنطقه
هناك التخطيط للرحله استغرق اسبوع وانسمح
لعدد قليل جدا من الصحفيين انهم يرافقوا
الرئيس في رحلته لكنهم اقسموا على السريه
واتخذ منهم كمان هواتفهم التفاصيل زادت
دراميه لما طلعت تقارير انه تم تنسيق
الزياره مع الروس كمان هذا الشيء اكدوا
النائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي اللي قال
انه بايدن ما راح كيف الا بعد ما حصل على
ضماننا لسلامته وقال كمان انه بايدن وعد
اوكرانيا بتزويدها بمزيد من الاسلحه من
بعد ما اخذ ضماننا على امنه وحمايته علشان
يقدر يزورها مسؤول كبير في امريكا رد بعد
هذا التصريح وقال احنا بلغناهم بالزياره
قبل ساعات بس من حصولها عموما بعيدا خلص
زيارته ورجعوا وارصوا مثل ما وصل بالقطار
اليوم خلال مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الخارجيه
العراقي فؤاد حسين من مقر الوزاره في
بغداد قطع الوزير المؤتمر الصحفي فجاه
وقالت الاماله العراقيه ما هي اليه سداد
الدين وروسيه على العراق وهل يمكن اتخاذ
اسلوب
الاستداد كما حدثت مع ايران
هذه المناقشات كانت جزءا من المناقشات
بيننا وبين السيد
وزير خارجيه روسيا الاتحاديه حينما زار
بغداد
اينما ذهب بغداد
مثل ما شفنا الوزير كان واضح عليه التعب
والاعياء وحاول يشرب الماء وانه يتمالك
نفسه لكن يبدو انه الوعكه الصحيه كانت
اقوى فغادر معتذرا عموما وسائل اعلام
عراقيه رجعت لاحقا نشرت مقطع قالت انه
للوزير وهو بيغادر وهو بصحه جيده ومبتسم
وسط الصحفيين اللي كانوا بيهنوا بالسلام
الحمد لله على السلامه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
من وقت ما ضرب الزلزال المدمر سوريا
وتركيا ولد نوع من الخوف والهلع عند اغلب
العالم وصار اي اشاره من الطبيعه كفيله
انه تقلب الدنيا وتعمل حاله رعب وفي لبنان
ومصر شايفين الايام الماضيه المنصات
مقلوبه بصور ومقاطع بتتكلم عن انحصار مياه
البحر وموجات تسونامي جايه وعلاقه بين هذا
وزلزال تركيا وسوريا في لبنان وفي منطقه
عدلون نشرت الناس صور وفيديوهات لمستويات
البحر وهي متراجعه وكمان معاها صور
لتصدعات في صخور على الشواطئ
جماعه الخير
البحر امين عدلون
مازال
صارت المويه
الله يستر
في مصر صار نفس الكلام والناس اتداولت صور
من شمال سيناء الانحصار البحر وقالوا انه
تراجع عشره و15 متر وانه هذه ظاهره اول
مره بتصير الرعب والخوف اللي سببته هذه
الصور والمقاطع دفع المراكز المختصه فورا
انها ترد وتوضح خاصه لما الناس ربطت
الموضوع بالزلزال وكلام عن تسونامي قادم
المجلس الوطني للبحوث العلميه في لبنان
وضح في بيان انه تراجع مياه البحر مرتبط
علميا بحركه المد هو الجزر واللي قد تكون
اقوى في بعض السنوات وانه الطقس الصافي
وعدم وجود عواصف او امواج جعل ملاحظه وجود
الجزر اكثر وضوحا المجلس صحه انه تراجع
البحر بسبب حتميه وصول امواج تسونامي وفي
مصر كمان المعهد القومي للبحوث الفلكيه
صرح بنفس الكلام تقريبا وهذا توضيح حصري
لنا من الدكتور جاد القاضي رئيس المعهد
اولا من خلال البيانات المعهد يسجلها وعدد
مشدات اخرى هيئه الشواطئ ومعه البحوث
الشواطئ المعدلات اللي موجوده لانخفاض
منسوب سطح البحر او تذبذب منصوب سطح البحر
دي معدلات طبيعيه خالص في وقتها لانه احنا
في نهايه الشهر العربي احنا عارفين ان في
علاقه وطيله ما بين القمر والارض بنسميها
المد والجزر فده احد الحيثيات الجزاء
التانيه ان على مدار العام في مواسم بيبقى
فيها انخفاض نسبي
واوقات بيكون فيها ارتفاع نسبي فده على
مدار العام
شهر فبراير ومارس من الاواخر بيكون فيها
انخفاض لكن المعدلات المرصوده حاليا مش زي
الارقام اللي بنسمعها 10 وخمسار متر القصه
كلها يعني لا تتعدى الواحد متر ودي زي ما
قلت لحضراتكم يعني في النطاق الامن
والمسموع الجزء الثاني من الموضوع ده
مالوش علاقه لما يتردد على السوشيال ميديا
اذا كان مرتبط بزلزال بتاع تركيا وان كان
في تحذير في وقت ما من موجات تسونامي او
مد بحري الكلام ده ملوش علاقه تماما بعيد
عن الصحه وعن اي محتوى علمي لهذا لهذه
الظاهره
اهلا من جديد اهلا ماسك قلب الدنيا من كم
شهر بخدمه تويتر بلو اللي هي الخدمه
المدفوعه من تويتر فمقابل 8 دولارات بتعطي
ميزات اضافيه للمشترك فيها وفي هذه الخدمه
يعني تحديدا وابرزها التوثيق يعني اي احد
حسابه موثق هو يبغى يفضل موثق لازم يدفع
اليوم
غار من ماسك فقامت متى اعلنت انه هي كمان
بتختبر خدمه اشتراك جديده بفلوس اسمها متى
وهذه على فيسبوك وانستجرام ومقابل 11
دولار وتسعه وتسعين سنت على الموقع و14
دولار وتسعه وتسعين سنت على اجهزه ابل
واندرويد وبتقول متى بعنوانها ان الخدمه
هدفها انه صناع المحتوى يتعزز وجودهم
وبتستعرض لائحه من المميزات اللي بيحصل
عليها المشترك واللي ابرزها التوثيق ومنها
كمان انه في حاله الحاجه لمساعده حيكون في
تواصل
مع بني ادم لانه العادي انه صاروا انه
الواحد ترد عليه اله هذا اذا لاقيه طبعا
اصلا او اذا ردت عليه يعني اصلا طبعا هذا
قلب الدنيا والكل جالس بيقول ايش فيه خلاص
كذا التوثيق صار متاح لاي شخص بيدفع فلوس
وانه كده يعني عادي يعني التوثيق هذا غير
كمان في ناس شايفه انه في ناس مو محتاجه
تدفع مشاهير ومعروفين لازم حساباتهم اصلا
تكون موثقه وانه ما ينفع اي شخص يدفع
يتوثق حسابه بعد تويتر بلوه ومتى
شبه متاح للجميع احنا سالناكم على
حساباتنا لو انتم شايفين انه التوثيق بدا
يفقد قيمته لما صار بمقابل مادي واجاباتكم
جاءت كالتالي 73% اجابوا انه نعم ايه بدا
يفقد قيمته و23% شافوا انه لا ما فقد
قيمته عادي
طيب احنا معنا في الاستوديو المختص في
التقنيه كريم فريد اهلا فيك معنا يا كريم
يعني الواحد لما يشوف هذا الشيء اول شيء
لما نعملها ايلون ماسك قلنا ماسك دافع
مبلغ كبير وعنده مشاكل ماليه وبده يحل
الازمه طبيعي لكن لما تيجي متى وتعملها
اللي هم ارباح بالهبل اعلانات بالهبل كله
بالهبل ايش بيفكروا من ورا الموضوع اولا
متى عندهم مشكله كبيره زي بالضبط من في
الربع الاخير من عشرين واحد وعشرين متى
كان اجمالي دخلها حوالي 33 مليار دولار
وكان ارباحهم من التلاته وتلاتين مليار
دولار تقريبا 30% ولكن في الربع الاخير من
20 22 هامش ربحهم نزل تقريبا 14% فعندهم
ازمه كبيره التكلفه اعلى والدخل من
الاعلانات وغيرها كبير جدا مش كبير جدا
يغطي التكلفه ويحافظ على مستوى الربح اللي
كانوا متعودين عليها
بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي المعلنين المشاكل
والازمات اللي مرت بها متى الخصوصيه العام
الركود العام حل الاقتصاديه وهكذا
خفضوا من عدد موظفين اهم يعني
الان لما يعملوا خطوه زي هذه بعد ماسك سوى
هذه الخطوه هل هو اقرار منهم بانه اللي
ماشي عليه ايرين صح ولا انه فكره طلعت من
عنده قالوا اوكي حلوه زي فيسبوك ومتى
عملوا مع كل حاجه تقريبا شافوا غيرهم
بيعملوها تجليد نوعا ما بيحاولوا ان هم
يقتبسوها او اعتقد ان المصطلح كويس
لان صار في جدل على هذا الموضوع خصوصا لما
اخذوا الستوريز من سناب بالضبط فهنا هم
اخذوا الفكره ولكن الفكره في النهايه هي
مدخل كويس وكان من الضروري في مرحله من
المراحل ان نظام الاشتراكات يدخل عالم
المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لان لازم يحصل
نقله ان اعلانات مش كل الناس عايزه تشوف
اعلانات وحجم الاعلانات اصبح مزعج بشكل
كبير فكان لازم يحصل ان يكون في مصدر تاني
للدخل للشركات وفي نفس الوقت
السابسكريبشنز او الاشتراكات تتيح
للمستخدمين بعض المميزات استخدم
ودلوقتي بعده يستخدمه التوثيق حاله من ان
هم تاني موقع التواصل مبنيه على جذب
الانتباه
ادفعوا مقابل الواجهه الاجتماعيه وفي
المقابل تدريجيا يتم تقديم خدمات اكبر
11 دولار او ثمانيه دولار بطلت توجهها
اجتماعيه اصبحت واقعه وهنا هيوصل هيوصلنا
لنقله تانيه واعتقد ان هنا نقله صحيه نوعا
ان مع الوقت لو استمر الموضوع بالشكل ده
وبقى فيه اهتمام كبير به وزي ما احنا
شايفين من تويتر كل الناس تقريبا بقوم
بالضبط ولكن مع اعتقد ان دوت هيسمح ان على
الاقل عدد الحسابات الوهميه ممكن يبتدي
يقل وهنا يكون صحي اكتر على المدى الطويل
اوكي هذه نقطه مهمه مره واعتقد انه في طرق
كثيره اصلا لما بنفتح الحساب والكلام هذا
كله يمكن التعامل فيها والتحقق من الحساب
مو وهمي بس انه لما نعطي اشاره هذه لكل
احد هنا صار عندك مشكله طب يعني ايش الفرق
بين الشخص اللي بيدفع وبين يعني مثلا هل
جيزي وبيونسي هيدفعوا مثلا هل مثلا يعني
حسابات رؤساء الدول وكذا حيدفعوا هم اكيد
بيقدروا يدفعوا ولكن هنا الفرق هيكون
مختلف ان زي ما الو ماسك عمل عمل تيرج
مختلفه عمل كذا شكل
فعمل الحسابات البيزنس والناس المعلنين
عمل لهم شكل مختلف وعلامه
ذهبيه عشان يحسسهم ان هم مختلفين عمل
الحسابات الحكوميه
ورؤساء الدول وهكذا علامه رماديه والناس
العاديه اللي هم عامه الناس عمل لهم
العلامه الزرقاء فهنا اعتقد ان هيكون في
شكل مشابه وفي النهايه هنوصل ان كل الناس
يبقوا والواجهه الاجتماعيه ما لهاش اي
كل الروس سوا يعني
مثلا لو وصلنا مثلا لو رجعنا للانستقرام
تحديدا يمكن لانه الانستجرام اعرف كثير
ناس فاتحين عليه حسابات اللي هي بزنس
وبيشتغلوا منها بزنس واشتغلوا صراحه فترات
طويله الى ان حصلوا على علامه توثيق من
انستغرام اللي هو يعد من اصعب منصات اللي
تحصل فيها على التوثيق طيب الان لما صار
الموضوع بفلوس انت يعني ما عاد في يعني
هدول ضريتهم الانفلونسرز اللي عندك او
اصحاب الحسابات هذولي ما اعتقدش ان في ضرر
لهم فعلي لان القيمه الحقيقيه هي للمحتوى
اللي بيقدموه فلو هم بيقدموا محتوى قوي
وعندهم تفاعل عندهم جمهور وهكذا ان يكون
في غيرهم موثقين ما اعتقدش انها حتسبب اي
ضرر مثلا او اللي عندهم يعني كان اول انه
هم الموثقين تعرف عارف عارف
الحقيقي
ولكن ممكن تدي للناس ثانيه فرصه ان هم
يظهروا ناس تانيه فرصه ان هم يقدروا
موهبتهم يوروا منتجاتهم
غاضبه جدا من هذا الموضوع بتقول بس كفايه
جسيم ندفع في كل مكان مش رح ندفع لكم لا
يا متى ولا يا تويتر قديش هالكلام واقعي
للاسف هيدفعه
من الاخر
ندفع مش مشكله لان في الاخر هتلاقي اكونت
ماشي لوحده كده من غير علامه توثيق الناس
هتبقى بتبصله
كل الناس
كنا يعني يا الله
بنشوف اشياء عجيبه هنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا في الاستوديو المختص في
التقنيه كريم فريد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
باط الدردشه اللي هو شات جي بي تي حديث
الساعه حول العالم سواء علامه التكنولوجيا
او حتى غيره واليوم الضجه اللي عاملها
ترجمه في تصدره لغلاف مجله تايم الامريكيه
الغلاف كان عباره عن محادثه بين المجله
وفيها المجله بتاخد رايه في تقريرها عن
سباق التسلح بالذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم
وهو بيجاوبها ونزلوا كمان على تويتر نص
فيديو المحادثه
كمان بدا يعمل مقابلات فيعني الله يستر
كمان حتى على وظيفتي فالرجل الاعمال
الشهير بيلزو رئيس وزراء بريطانيا
كانوا ضيوف على عمل معهم مقابله جاوبوا
فيها على اسئله طرحها البط حول الابتكار
والتكنولوجيا والذكاء الاصطناعي
بالقيس بالمناسبه من اشد المعجبين بهذه
التكنولوجيا ومن كم يوم كان له تصريح وصف
التطور في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي باهم
ابتكار في الوقت الحالي
وغيرهم من بطص المحادثات عامل للعالم لعده
اسباب واحنا ناقشناها حتى اكثر من مره
منها انه بيسيطر على الانسان او انه بيعبر
عن مشاعر واحاسيس او بهين حتى اللي بيتكلم
معهم هذا غير دعوات تنظيم وتقنين القطاع
الجديد والليثيرين بيعتبروه مخيف ومن
المخاوف المثاره حوله كمان العنصريه
والانحياز وعدم الموضوعيه وناس بتقول انه
لان الفكر الليبرالي هو اللي مسيطر على
كبرى شركات التكنولوجيا فحكما
منحاز وهذا الشيء يعني ظهرت منه ملامح امس
لما انتشرت لائحه انتجتها باسماء مشاهير
مثيرين للجدل وهل يجب انه يعاملهم البط
بطريقه خاصه فمثلا ترامب والين ماسك قال
عنهم جدليين وكذلك بوتين في
وغيرهم ما شافهم جدليين لاحظتوا الاسماء
يعني في الناحيتين كيف الفرق بينهم عموما
ما فوتها وعاد تغريد القائمه لكنه اكتفى
بالتعليق على هذه القائمه واللي جاي فيها
بعلامتين تعجب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم انا
عدو القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]